what i want to share with you is the one
sales tactic
that is directly made over 35 million
dollars for my company
[Music]
so when i was at my own gym
back in the day probably eight years ago
um i was really struggling
right and i was traveling to come back
home or something
and during a layover i saw this guy that
i used to go to college with
and he uh he was i didn't think this guy
was like that much smarter than me and
like definitely
like i was in some classes i was like i
don't think this guy's that bright
and he sits down next to me and he says
uh he's like oh how's your gym i heard
you got a gym and i was like oh you know
it's going well i was like trying to
be cool and he's like yeah i've got this
supplement store
i was like oh that's awesome he's like
well i've got two locations now i was
like oh
well fancy you um and i said well what
do you guys do like a month
he says i don't know we do like 70 80
000 a month and i was like in
supplements he was like yeah
and at that moment it was like my mind
broke i was like
if this guy can do this i'm gonna find a
way like i was like i've got this whole
gym full of people and i don't sell them
supplements
and so when i came back i was like 100
committed to selling supplements i was
like i'm going to figure out how to do
this
and every single client will walk into
my facility after i would sell them our
service package i was like hey
buy these supplements right uh and they
were like
no i'm not going to and it felt horrible
and i literally just
again and again and again i just kept
getting beat up and i bought all this
inventory after
i talked to that guy and so this cache
is just sitting on my shelf and i was
like i have to find a way to move this
stuff
and so one day i think i had 15 or 20
consultation sites
i had sold a bunch of people into a new
program that was starting
and i was doing all the 101 orientations
that was probably like 15 orientations
deep and i just headed no after no after
no
after no and finally i was sitting down
and this nice lady walked in and she had
like a nice ring and a nice purse and i
was like okay
if i don't sell this woman i'm going to
kill myself and so
and she was like super upbeat and
anybody who's ever done sales like you
know when you see that person you're
like i'm definitely closing this one
like i i have to close this one like
this is how i pay my bills
and so she sits down and i remember
getting to the end of the presentation
and i just said instead of my normal
pitch around like hypertrophy and
maintaining body mass and just a whole
bunch of jargon that she would never
even understand i said
hey uh so with the program was like do
you want to do uh you want chocolate or
vanilla
for your protein and she was like which
one do you like
i was like chocolate she was like all
right i'll take one of those
and i was like didn't want to scare her
away so i was like
uh i've got uh for the pre-workout do
you want to do
kiwi or strawberry i i like the kiwi she
was like okay i'll do that one
and i didn't want to sell any more
because i was afraid that she would
somehow back out
and so and i didn't want her to like
make any other purchasing decisions so i
said
do you want to just use the card you
have them file and she was like yeah
that's fine
and then i took these off the shelf and
i and i slid them over at her
and she grabbed them and she smiled and
she walked out of the facility
and i made my first supplement sale and
i was like
holy [ __ ] i didn't even talk at all
about what these even did or how to take
them or what the benefits were
i just simply asked her which one she
wanted and the key was
i didn't ask her whether she wanted them
i asked her
which one she wanted and as soon as i
realized that
that is when i was introduced to the
assumed close
all right it is one of the strongest
upsells
in all of business all right like i
can't tell you whenever
whenever i hear someone if there's every
sales process that generates
tons and tons of traffic and they're
closing anywhere in the 80
plus range i usually know that it's an
upsell
all right and the beauty of an assumed
close is that the prospect is choosing
between two options that both are buying
from you rather than whether
or not they're going to purchase and so
the beauty is if you can construct your
conversations in a way that makes the
sale seamless
and make it assume that they're going to
have this extra thing with your program
you can immediately upsell a big big big
percentage of customers whereas maybe
normally you might close one out of
three or one out of four
or if you're really good one out of two
of customers who walk in the door
with an assumed close as an upsell you
can sell nine out of ten
nine and a half out of ten of the people
that you sit in front of and you can
close them at higher tickets
at higher percentages and part of the
reason is because in an upsell
opportunity you're selling to a customer
who already knows and trusts you
right and if you pair the fact that they
already know and trust you with the fact
that you already have
a purchase that's already happened you
have their their information on file
and then you simply present them with an
either or option that both include
buying
you will typically get a huge percentage
to take that option
and so um this this assumed closed
rapidly transform our business i ended
up making just as much if not more from
the supplement sales in profit
than i did for my actual facility uh it
became a staple
in all the locations that i had i was
able to cover all of my advertising
spends simply from the upsells
and so that took all of what used to be
my service revenue and just turned that
into profit because i could cover all my
acquisition costs simply with the
upsells
um i taught this to all of the
facilities that we had and they
ultimately use that for
uh selling prestige labs which is the
brand of supplements that we have that
pays really really high margins for gyms
and so that
single experience where that lady bless
her soul
just said yes to the either or option is
what significantly changed
a huge part of my life and so anyways i
hope
you take something from that i hope
there's there's something you can look
in terms of your sales process in terms
of something you could upsell it doesn't
have to be a product it can be a service
um it could be you know it can obviously
be any kind of retail stuff physical
products is really easy because you
already sold service so
next that you want to think about what's
the next natural thing that they're
going to want to need
or or want or going to have to normally
buy on their journey
and if you're like i don't know how to
find something like that you just simply
look at what the normal things that a
normal
that a customer will buy in addition to
your services as a result of the
decision
you know fitness is an easy one people
go buy clothing fitness clothes they buy
shoes
they might buy some at-home stuff they
might start downloading some apps they
might get
different groceries uh so that's food or
food prepping food prep materials
a crock pot like all of those things are
things to be accompanied than obviously
supplements
and so a lot of times when a consumer
makes a decision to work with you on a
service side there's other
additional purchases that they're going
to make and if you can if you can
if you can predict what those are which
you should know and weave those into
your sales process as an either or
decision
you will usually get a very big
percentage to uptake and a lot of times
those upsells can be all profit for you
and even offset the entire cost of
acquisition
of getting a new customer so i can't
even stress how how impactful this was
in my life
and so anyways i hope you found that
valuable hope that was cool if you like
this stuff
you know like subscribe all that kind of
jazz um and i think i've got some
trainings that you can go through for
free
and go click do that and uh catch you
soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you